explosive and exclusive new information
will put further pressure on special
prosecutor Bob Muller to resign that's
the focus of tonight's angle last night
we brought you a disturbing and
revealing report about FBI investigator
Peter struck who was relieved of his
duties in the Muller office after it was
revealed that he texted anti-trump
messages during the 2016 presidential
debates previously struck had been a top
investigator on the Hillary Clinton
email probe it was responsible for
watering down the language then FBI
director Comey used to describe mrs.
Clinton's handling of classified
information on her private email server
isn't that neat the original language
called her grossly negligent which by
the way can be a criminal violation of
the applicable statute but it was
changed by struck to merely extremely
careless
once again Hillary ends up skating for
conduct that would have put any of us
behind bars
you see struck was kind of a Forrest
Gump of the FBI but without any of the
endearing qualities why do I say that
he was present during Hillary's
one-and-only interview at the FBI he was
an agent who interviewed Hillary's
longtime aides Huma Abedin and Cheryl
Mills and then he helped grill former
national security adviser Michael Flynn
on January 24th so I don't question what
the heck was truck's magic touch
why have all of the hundreds of lawyers
in the FBI was here are we so lucky to
get these plum assignments well I think
we all know why and as a weird aside -
this whole fiasco if you go to Struck's
Wikipedia page it reads that the website
is considering his whole page for
deletion
that's a bit odd in fact as far as the
media go well they spent the day either
ignoring or downplaying Struck's
conflict of interest
mr. struck this FBI agent in charge it
doesn't change anything the one that has
been removed from the investigation
doesn't change anything
that FBI agents are people who work on
behalf of the government aren't supposed
to have any political feelings or any
political biases you know that's a
that's a little bit of an overstatement
right they aren't there is
politicization here but also this is
this is the president continuing to go
after American law enforcement okay I
have a question will the media be able
to downplay all of Mother Muller's other
tainted investigators the conflicts in
the mother shop don't stop with struck
according to documents obtained by
Judicial Watch former head of do J's
criminal fraud division Andrew Weissman
emailed acting Attorney General Sally
Yates praising her for refusing to
enforce Trump's travel ban in court on
January 30th shortly after Trump fired
her Weitzman wrote I'm so proud and in
awe thank you so much all of my deepest
respects
Andrew Weissman oh isn't that sweet so
naturally when the time came to choose
his deputy special counsel Muller chills
Weissman who was also his former partner
at the law firm Wilmer Cutler think
about it Weissman chose him to be the
number two guy on an investigation that
could lead to the impeachment of the
President of the United States given
those statements when he was on the
record celebrating Yates remember she
was an instant hero of the left because
she refused to enforce that same
president's lawful executive order my
friends we are talking willful defiance
of the chief executive officer of the
United States Trump is their boss it's
simple folks
Wiesmann must be removed from the Muller
team because of the apparent and real
conflict of interest his presence
represents and finally our exclusive
report on yet another Muller prosecutor
who's compromised this time because of
her alliances to the Obama White House
meet Jeannie Rhee she was hired by
Muller in early June and also a partner
of Weissman and also of Muller's old law
firm will
more cutler previously she was a deputy
assistant AG in the Office of Legal
Counsel that's for Obama and that meant
she gave official legal advice to the
Obama White House on policy but that's
not even the most interesting part of
the story we've learned exclusively from
sources on Capitol Hill that just weeks
before joining the special prosecutors
team Ari was the personal attorney a
former deputy Obama national security
adviser Ben Rhodes and was in fact his
point of contact with the House Intel
committee in its investigation into
Russia now she did actually appear with
Rhodes at his closed-door interview last
spring but that was only because by then
she was already working with Muller oh
and did I forget to mention that she
also represented the Clinton Foundation
and donated about nine thousand dollars
to Hilary and her fellow Democrats once
again another member of the Muller team
has been exposed for brazen partisanship
which at the very least very least
represents the appearance of a conflict
of interest if not an actual one let's
face it what we're seeing here is a
pattern and practice of Muller hiring
known Clinton and Obama political
insiders and boosters supporters to undo
a presidential election that was the
election of Donald Trump what's the
common denominator at the three amigos
here well they all hate Trump but more
than that their political adversaries
given the gravity of the situation given
all that's at stake for America robert
muller needed to assemble a team of
unassailable professionals they needed
to run that investigation professionally
professionally and without any question
instead as we're documenting night after
night what Muller did he hired a
pedigreed team of obvious partisans a
revolving door from working for
political opponents of Trump to working
on the investigation into Trump and his
suppose it Russian ties what a total
travesty
should all step aside they should all go
back to their old law firm they're old
buddies they're including Bob Muller and
that's the angle